[Music]
body back how am i doing the real
question is how are you doing fine
but let's talk about you what's been
going on oh just so many things you know
I've been so busy lately it's crazy busy
with what there's just so many projects
up in the air right now for me I'm just
kind of waiting to see how they come
through you know yeah it's great
you know I've been writing more I've
been hitting the gym you're just
focusing on stuff I care about well good
you look great I mean you look the same
as you did in college Wow you know me
I'm afraid of change you you were
interning at that tech company yeah I'm
still there yeah still doing the same
thing you know every day again and again
but I love it still it's it's it's great
so it's meaningful work and it's awesome
are you still with Teddy no we broke up
but it's for the best it was mutual I'm
sorry to hear that
Wow well don't be too sorry it's not
like I'm gonna sleep with you just cuz
I'm single oh don't worry I don't want
to sleep with you either you know I like
riding solo right now you know cheers to
that my friend
[Music]
so you want a family eventually oh no I
had my tubes tied last year